honest this will really make me cry but
this will be the last time that
we're ever asked about the show as a
group that we will do this like
we're not going to do this again in 15
more years the friends cast will always
be there for each other
but they say their new hbo max special
is the last time that they will reunite
publicly the long-awaited reunion
dropped thursday
and at the end of the special the cast
gets emotional
realizing that it's probably the last
time they will all be together
talking about the show for fans but it
won't be the last time they all hang out
i'll tell you one thing we're not
waiting so long to have a dinner no
we're not
no we will not wait that long to get
together and they agreed
that it was nice for a few days to be
back on the old warner brothers
soundstage
back in the apartment and coffee shop
sets they called home for 10 seasons
i knew it was going to be awesome to see
these five people what i did not
take into account was being back on the
sets
in this environment and it's uh it's um
it's pretty cool we became
best friends who just the chemistry the
whole thing
it was life-changing and it forever will
be not just for us but for people who
watch it
and all that echoes what the cast told
et about their tight bond
even 17 years after the show wrapped
all i can say is that there was
something that was
laid down at the very very beginning
that kind of went into our neural
pathways that we
instantly it was in our dna that we were
family we were going to take care of
each
other it's unexplainable but we're the
most grateful women that i know who have
been able to be a part of something like
this it's a very loving
tight-knit group and when we see each
other it's a it's a very heartwarming
thing
from the first table read of the pilot
without having met
any of the others beforehand we all felt
kind of an instant chemistry
going way back but during the hbo max
special
the cast explained why they aren't down
to bring back their famous characters
they ended the show very nicely
everyone's lives are very nice and they
would have to unravel
all those good things in order for there
to be stories and
yeah i don't want anyone's happy ending
unraveled so
safe to say this reunion really did mark
the end of an era
and the whole thing had the cast super
emotional
hi holy crap
oh word all right well where's the
tissue box
the cast got teary-eyed seeing the set
for the first time in nearly two decades
wow
[Music]
this is beautiful it's beautiful look at
that
matt leblanc wiped away courtney cox's
tears and
matthew perry got choked up talking
about how they are all still friends
all these years later the best way that
i can describe it is
after the show was over at a party
or any any kind of social gathering
if one of us bumped into each other that
was it that was the end of the night
you just sat with them sat with the
person
all night long i remember that that was
it
no but really where are the tissues i'm
not laughing i'm crying because it's so
true this is
sat down with the cast they opened up
about being all in their feels and those
tear-filled moments
it was the most emoti i i i had slept so
well the night before
woke up i wasn't nervous at all just
feeling good the first question like
how do you feel i was like and then
started crying and then i walked on the
set and i had no idea
that seeing everything look exactly the
same and these incredible friends that
even though i see
these two a lot i i still was just like
jenny are you trying to switch to me
she's like yeah it was just the most
emotional thing and once her
gates opened then it was i couldn't shut
it off you couldn't even i could plug it
i didn't no
nothing
[Music]